Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
La France est-elle en train
de perdre l'Afrique ?
Une question d'actualité.
Des pays africains de l'ouest,
mais aussi
d'ailleurs, en Afrique,
se font entendre
des "Non à la France".
S'agit-il de solder
notre passé colonial en Afrique,
en visant une Françafrique
désormais
en mort cérébrale ?
Même l'opération Barkhane,
engagée en 2014,
pour empêcher
le dépeçage du Mali,
par les djihadistes d'AQMI,
a pris fin,
en se cherchant
d'autres missions
que strictement sécuritaires.
Il incombe désormais
à des milices militaires russes,
sous le nom de Wagner,
d'assurer et d'oeuvrer
avec les forces armées africaines,
pour assurer
une rente sécuritaire
à des Etats instables,
et piller en retour
les ressources disponibles.
S'agit-il
d'un ressentiment ?
D'une rancoeur ?
D'une défiance politique,
à l'égard d'une France
prédatrice
des précieuses ressources
et autres matières premières
d'une Afrique
qui demeure un...
un continent, pardon,
richement doté,
nonobstant la paupérisation
des populations,
et un développement
insuffisant.
A la vérité,
le pré carré africain de la France
en matière économique
est en voie
de rétrécissement constant,
au regard de la mondialisation,
qui permet
à la Chine,
à la Turquie,
au Brésil, à la Russie
de s'emparer des marchés africains.
Bref, la France ne semble plus
l'alliée privilégiée
de l'Afrique de l'Ouest.
D'autres puissances prédatrices
se bousculent,
dans la salle d'attente africaine.
Pour quelles finalités
politiques et stratégiques
de ce continent africain,
qui verra, en 2055,
sa population doubler,
et pour quelle politique africaine
de la France ?
Nous allons tenter
de répondre
à toutes ces questions
avec mes invités,
que je vous présente.
Edouard Guillaud,
vous êtes amiral,
ancien chef d'état-major des armées.
Georges Serre,
vous êtes diplomate,
et vous avez été ambassadeur
en Côte d'Ivoire.
Calixthe Beyala,
vous êtes romancière.
Antoine... Glaser,
pardon,
vous êtes journaliste
et écrivain.
Et Nicolas Baverez,
vous êtes avocat,
politologue et essayiste.
-Alors, vous venez
de voir la citation
que j'ai prise,
qui est de vous,
Calixthe Beyala.
"Les rêves de liberté
"des Africains sont restés
"coincés entre les mains
des françafricains."
Avant d'aborder la politique,
l'économie et la sécurité,
comment vous percevez
la dimension psychologique
de ce ressentiment
antifrançais,
qui se fait entendre
à Bamako, à Dakar,
à Yaoundé, Bangui,
Libreville,
N'Djamena ?
-D'abord,
excusez-moi de penser
qu'il n'y a pas
de ressentiment antifrançais.
Les Français, en tant que tels,
ne sont pas persécutés,
en Afrique.
On peut être français
et vivre à Douala, à Yaoundé,
tout à fait en sécurité.
C'est un ressentiment
antisystème, plutôt,
anti-françafricain.
Il y a un groupe de personnes,
des Noirs et des Blancs,
qui se sont organisées
à piller ce continent. Donc,
par facilité intellectuelle,
ont dit "antifrançais".
On peut pas être antifrançais,
puisque,
pour construire
une Afrique nouvelle...
-Oui, mais quand on dit
non à la France, ça veut pas dire
qu'on l'embrasse !
-Ca veut pas dire non plus
qu'on la déteste.
C'est quand même assez ambigu,
puisque
la plupart des étudiants africains
veulent
venir faire leurs études
en France.
Donc, c'est très paradoxal,
très ambigu.
On peut pas résumer par :
"La France doit foutre le camp",
"La France doit partir",
et puis
"Marre des Africains".
Ce n'est pas ainsi
qu'on gère les problèmes.
Il faut toujours trouver
des conciliations, des dialogues.
Evidemment, la population
dans la rue n'a pas forcément
des outils pour exprimer...
-Oui, mais,
"Non à la France",
alors que la Françafrique
n'est plus là !
-Elle est bien là,
à travers des Africains,
à travers des Français.
Ils tiennent l'économie,
ils tiennent la Françafrique.
Ils contrôlent les choses,
pas la France institutionnelle
qui est là.
-Laissez-moi avoir
d'autres avis.
George Serre,
comment vous appréhendez
ce "Non à la France",
qu'on entend
dans ces capitales africaines ?
-Il faut quand même
savoir raison garder.
Je suis assez d'accord :
c'est pas un non
aux Français,
et "Non à la France",
c'est une réaction
contre une politique,
c'est un moment bien précis
dans le temps.
Et ça se passe
dans certaines capitales,
pas dans toute l'Afrique.
Donc, il faut être
un peu plus mesuré.
Quand on a, par exemple,
au Burkina Faso,
une attaque contre l'ambassade
et une destruction
des instituts français
de Bobo-Dioulasso
et de la capitale.
Quelques jours après,
il y a
des journalistes burkinabés,
mais aussi ivoiriens
et d'autres pays,
qui font une émission,
et les remarques qu'on entend :
"Dommage d'avoir cassé
"cet outil de travail
qui nous est utile,
"à nous, Burkinabés
et Ivoiriens."
Donc, vous voyez,
ce n'est pas non plus...
C'est une présentation
un petit peu virulente
de quelque chose qui...
Alors, la Françafrique,
c'est un concept
qui a été inventé
il y a plus de 50 ans,
par Félix Houphouët-Boigny.
C'est une image
dans un moment précis.
Aujourd'hui,
ça a été utilisé
par un certain nombre d'ONG,
par des partis politiques.
On voit ce que ça veut dire.
Mais c'est un peu
comme la girafe :
on voit ce que c'est,
mais c'est difficile à décrire,
aujourd'hui.
-Mais alors, donc,
ça existe, ou non, Nicolas Baverez,
la Françafrique ?
-Je pense que c'est, aujourd'hui
largement un mythe,
mais c'est intéressant de voir
pourquoi le mythe,
aujourd'hui, est utilisé.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Il y a eu trois grands moments.
Le moment des indépendances,
en effet un échec assez majeur
de la conversion de l'Afrique,
qui était mal partie
pour la démocratie
et le développement. C'est vrai,
vous l'avez rappelé,
les années 60,
c'est cette grande époque
de la Françafrique.
Ensuite, à partir des années 90,
il y a deux mouvements intéressants.
Il y a une démocratisation
de l'Afrique
et puis, par ailleurs, l'Afrique
entre dans la mondialisation.
Elle s'ouvre et,
vous l'avez rappelé, elle a
des partenaires qui se diversifient
et on a un 3e moment,
aujourd'hui,
où, en même temps
qu'elle s'ouvrait,
avec la fin de la guerre froide,
l'Afrique
n'était plus un enjeu
géopolitique
et stratégique
comme on l'avait connu auparavant.
Elle l'est redevenue parce qu'on a
une grande confrontation
entre les démocraties et que,
pour que des pays comme la Chine,
la Russie,
la Turquie, le fait d'être
en Afrique...
-On va rentrer
dans le détail de ces choses.
-Mais ça explique pourquoi
la Françafrique,
parce qu'il y a une compétition
des puissances en Afrique
et que d'autres puissances
utilisent le mythe
de la Françafrique
pour le retourner
contre la France.
C'est ce qui s'est passé au Mali
et au Burkina Faso.
-Antoine Glaser, la Françafrique...
A l'époque du général de Gaulle,
on identifiait "l'Africain"
du général :
c'était Jacques Foccart.
Mais aujourd'hui, qui est capable
de citer le nom
de "l'Africain" d'Emmanuel Macron ?
Ca existe ou ça n'existe plus ?
Sincèrement ?
-Sincèrement,
le problème, c'est effectivement
un problème historique.
Il ne faut quand même pas oublier,
depuis les indépendances de 1960
jusqu'à la chute du mur de Berlin,
il y avait un système intégré,
politique, militaire, financier
extrêmement verrouillé,
les dirigeants africains
étaient cooptés par la France
mais, comme Houphouët-Boigny
ou Senghor, ils avaient souvent
été ministres
dans des gouvernements
français.
Des généraux comme Eyadéma au Togo
ou Bokassa en Centrafrique
avaient crapahuté
avec l'armée française en Indochine,
en Algérie...
Et l'erreur fondamentale...
Moi aussi, je trouve anachronique
de dire la Françafrique
quand vous avez connu ce que c'était
avec ce système intégré,
mais ce qui est incroyable,
c'est de refuser de parler
de cette époque.
Ce que veulent les jeunes,
maintenant, c'est...
Maintenant, on veut tirer
l'ardoise magique. Bien sûr
qu'on est dans une nouvelle
période de géopolitique.
La France n'a pas vu
l'Afrique se mondialiser.
Tout le monde regardait l'Europe,
la réunification de l'Allemagne,
mais qui regardait ce qui se passait
en Afrique ?
Même dans les milieux patronaux,
les gens étaient installés
en pensant que c'était
ad vitam aeternam
et je pense qu'on paye actuellement
ce refus...
Enfin, Emmanuel Macron...
Il y a eu le Rwanda, maintenant,
il veut ouvrir aussi les dossiers
sur le Cameroun, l'Algérie...
Mais à un moment donné,
surtout en 2017,
quand il est arrivé au pouvoir,
il a dit : "Les gars, on replie
les rétroviseurs,
"regardons devant.
Moi, j'ai pas connu ça,
"allons-y franchement."
Je pense que c'était une erreur.
Je pense
qu'il faut parler
de cette période
qui était, je termine là-dessus...
Pourquoi c'était une période
particulière ?
Parce que les propres alliés
de la France
laissaient la France
gérer ces pays à sa guise !
La France contrôlait
les marchés à 50-60 %.
Elle avait l'uranium,
le pétrole à bas prix.
C'était une période qui,
à la chute du mur de Berlin,
on a fait comme si...
La France
n'a pas vu l'Afrique se mondialiser.
C'est ça, le problème.
-Ecoutez, amiral,
vous avez été
chef d'état-major
et vous étiez,
si je puis dire,
en opération
au moment de l'intervention Serval
et Barkhane.
Vous n'êtes pas resté
longtemps après
comme chef d'état-major
mais vous avez supervisé.
Est-ce que vous avez ressenti,
à ce moment-là, une hostilité
des Africains à la présence
militaire française ?
-En réalité, à aucun moment.
Même aujourd'hui,
alors qu'on a vu effectivement
un certain nombre
de manifestations
dont on sait très bien...
Il suffit de regarder
les drapeaux étrangers
qui y sont montrés,
dont on sait très bien
qu'elles sont téléguidées.
A aucun moment, nous n'avons eu
la moindre difficulté.
La seule véritable difficulté
que nous avons rencontrée,
c'était de coopérer avec des armées
qui étaient des armées nationales,
qui étaient souvent, en réalité,
laissées pour compte
par les gouvernements locaux,
dont on peut dire...
Nous étions sans doute
un peu coupables de l'avoir accepté,
mais eux trouvaient très confortable
de laisser
les Français faire le travail
à leur place.
Donc on a été très bien reçus.
La libération
de Tombouctou,
la libération de Gao,
Ménaka, toute cette partie
du nord du Mali...
Mais également,
quelques années auparavant,
quand nous sommes intervenus
dans d'autres pays,
je pense à la Côte d'Ivoire
- et Georges Serre
peut en parler à sa maman -
et aussi
en République centrafricaine,
à peu près la même période.
Et, à chaque fois,
nous avons été très bien accueillis.
La difficulté
que nous avons rencontrée,
nous, Français,
pas "militaires français",
c'est qu'assez souvent,
nous avons considéré
qu'une opération militaire
se suffisait par elle-même
et était un tout.
En réalité, non.
Il y a un jour
avant l'opération militaire,
il y a un jour après.
Ce n'est qu'un petit moment
dans histoire d'un pays.
Il faut tenir compte
de ce qu'il y a avant
et préparer l'après.
-Vous voulez dire
qu'avant l'intervention
Serval et Barkhane,
il y a eu une préparation
politique insuffisante ?
-Non.
Pas avant l'intervention,
sur l'avant de l'intervention...
L'intervention de Serval,
on la voyait venir
depuis quelques années
parce que les groupes djihadistes
prenaient de plus en plus d'otages.
On se disait que ça allait exposer.
Et la surprise
a été que plusieurs groupes
s'allient alors que,
d'habitude, ils se...
ils se combattaient
les uns les autres.
Mais alliés, ils étaient
trop puissants
pour le gouvernement
de Bamako.
C'est pour ça
que nous sommes intervenus.
Par contre,
nous n'avons sans doute pas,
et là, je parle avec du recul
et je suis
quand même très prudent, préparé
la sortie non militaire de serval.
Qu'il y ait eu une sortie
qui s'appelait Barkhane,
c'était naturel,
c'était vraisemblablement
ce qu'il fallait faire
à ce moment-là,
de même qu'il est bien
qu'on en sorte aujourd'hui.
Mais il y a les à-côtés.
C'était la reconstruction :
il n'y avait plus
de dispensaires, le système
d'adduction d'eau de Tombouctou
avait été détruit,
qui venait du fleuve Niger,
il y a quand même 40 km,
c'est nous qui avons mis des pompes.
Mais ça ne suffisait pas.
Mais nous n'avons pas réouvert
ou aidé suffisamment à réouvrir
les écoles. Ca, c'est pas
directement les militaires.
Nous faisons partie d'un tout
qui s'appelle la France.
Nous n'avons pas, du coup,
donné les moyens aux agriculteurs
de pouvoir cultiver leurs champs
ou faire paître leurs troupeaux
pour les éleveurs,
aux petits commerces
de se réépanouir,
aux écoles de réouvrir.
C'est souvent là
que nous avons,
par peur d'être accusés
de néocolonialisme...
-Justement,
à ce sujet, Georges Serre,
vous êtes le diplomate,
dans cette...
assemblée-là.
Il y a beaucoup de puissances
européennes qui ont colonisé
des pays, en Afrique et ailleurs,
que ce soit la Belgique,
que ce soit la Grande-Bretagne,
que ce soit d'autres pays,
même l'Allemagne etc.
Finalement,
le colonialisme français,
c'est une repentance inextinguible.
Est-ce qu'il y a,
à votre avis,
quelque chose dans ce domaine...
Il hésite.
...de morbide
ou de pervers ?
Jusqu'à quand faut-il expier
d'avoir été colonialistes ?
-Alors moi, j'ai fait ambassadeur
en République Démocratique du Congo.
Et qu'est-ce que c'est confortable
d'être ambassadeur de France en RDC
puisque c'est la colonisation belge
qui est critiquée tous les jours.
Dont vous voyez, tout est relatif.
Il faut remettre les choses
en perspective.
Quand on est en Tanzanie,
on parle encore aujourd'hui
de la colonisation allemande
qui fut terrible.
Au Cameroun, la colonisation
allemande a été très dure aussi
mais il reste des choses
et, dans certaines régions
du Cameroun,
on parle encore allemand.
Là aussi,
on a des moments historiques
et on ne peut pas mesurer
à l'aune d'aujourd'hui
ce qui s'est passé autrefois.
-Mais on n'a pas fait pire
que le Commonwealth !
Qui est encore aujourd'hui,
même si c'est
de manière virtuelle...
-Le Commonwealth,
comme son nom l'indique,
c'est une association économique...
-Mais l'économie et la politique
ont parties liées.
-La France a essayé d'aller
un peu plus loin,
d'avoir quelque chose qui soit plus
que de l'économique.
C'est là qu'elle a peut-être péché
par orgueil et été plus loin
que ce qui était possible
en fonction de ce qui existait.
En même temps,
il y a vraiment
de très beaux restes
de ce qui s'est fait
en Afrique francophone.
Et d'ailleurs,
quand on est en Afrique du Sud,
beaucoup de Sud-Africains...
C'est d'ailleurs le pays du monde
où les alliances françaises
se développent le plus,
pour faire
du commerce avec le reste
de l'Afrique
dont une partie est francophone.
Donc ils vont
apprendre le français.
Quand on est canadien, on voit
que la langue française,
dans le cadre
de la francophonie,
est quelque chose
qui est assez porteur.
On est à 850 millions
de francophones,
en se projetant dans 25 ou 30 ans,
dont une grande partie d'Africains,
du continent africain.
Tout ça, il ne faut pas le voir
de manière aussi brutale.
C'est pas...
L'un ou l'autre,
c'est beaucoup plus nuancé.
-Nicolas Baverez, un mot
sur la repentance inextinguible,
jusqu'à la fin des temps ?
-Non...
Enfin,
ça n'a pas de sens.
On voit aujourd'hui
qu'il y a un ressentiment
et ce ressentiment,
c'est vrai qu'il est paradoxal
parce que les puissances coloniales,
aujourd'hui, en Afrique,
c'est la Chine - il n'y a qu'à voir
l'Ethiopie - c'est la Russie,
il n'y a qu'à voir
ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
en République centrafricaine
ou au Mali,
et c'est plus la France.
Donc dans l'héritage de la France,
évidemment, il y a un passé
qui est un passé violent,
conflictuel.
Il y a des instruments,
vous l'avez rappelé,
je voudrais revenir sur le fait
qu'il y a des instruments
qui sont très utiles
parce que l'avenir de l'Afrique,
c'est l'intégration.
On a des instruments d'intégration,
donc la langue française,
qui est la langue officielle,
et qui permet de dialoguer
sur une partie du continent,
il y a le franc CFA
qui permet...
-On va rentrer
dans tous ces éléments.
-Il y a le droit des affaires,
donc il y a des instruments
d'intégration qui existent
et qui sont positifs.
Mais cette logique du ressentiment,
je pense que de toute manière,
on ne construit jamais l'avenir
sur le ressentiment.
Mais comme il a été dit,
pour dépasser le ressentiment,
il faut pouvoir s'expliquer,
communiquer.
C'est ce qui a été fait
entre la France et l'Allemagne
et c'est ce qui peut tout à fait
être fait par ailleurs.
Et le Commonwealth n'est pas
non plus...
Tout ne va pas si bien que ça
dans le Commonwealth.
-Alors Calixthe Beyala, il faut
qu'on essaie de purger la question.
-Oui, je pense, aussi !
-Parce que,
le populisme, l'autoritarisme,
le nationalisme
sont partout dans le monde
et on le constate
de plus en plus.
Et si vous me permettez,
l'Afrique n'y échappe pas.
Comme tous les continents,
il y a partout
cette montée de populisme
et de nationalisme.
Est-ce que vous n'avez pas
le sentiment qu'en Afrique,
la vindicte
antifrançaise
est constitutive
de ce populisme
et de ce nationalisme ?
Est-ce que vous n'avez pas
ce sentiment-là ?
Je sais bien qu'un nationalisme
se construit par rapport
à un autre nationalisme.
Comment vous expliquez
que c'est le sentiment antifrançais
qui nourrit,
dans ce cas-là, le nationalisme ?
-Avant de vous répondre,
je vais vous rassurer
sur ce plateau.
Le continent africain,
notamment l'Afrique francophone,
ne connaîtra plus d'impérialisme.
Je pense que ce qui est
en train d'être fait
est fait pour que plus jamais
aucun peuple, que ce soit la Russie,
que ce soient les Chinois,
ne puisse dominer.
Un travail est fait,
et j'aimerais que vous m'écoutiez
un tout petit peu,
ce que vous appelez ressentiment,
c'est que l'histoire
n'a pas été purgée
et je m'explique, monsieur.
C'est que, par exemple,
dans le cas du Cameroun,
on a eu un colonialisme,
on a eu la guerre.
Moi, j'ai vécu
cette guerre-là enfant,
je veux dire que j'ai vu des morts,
j'ai vécu dans des cadavres,
entre 0 et 15 ans,
on suspendait des hommes.
Je ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé
et, jusque aujourd'hui,
personne ne m'a dit
ce qui s'est passé,
et j'aimerais beaucoup
qu'on me le dise.
Ce qui se passe,
c'est que les Africains
ne veulent plus de la domination
d'une monnaie appelée le franc
CFA.
-On va entrer dans le détail,
mais restons sur les aspects
psychologiques.
-Puisqu'on a abordé ces questions,
je préfère en parler.
-On va en parler
dans le détail.
-Sur le plan psychologique,
c'est pas des nationalismes
mais du panafricanisme
qui se construit,
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes
en train de vouloir
mettre à plat
même les nationalismes.
Ca ne nous sert pas,
les nationalismes,
puisque ça draine des haines,
de la xénophobie, en Afrique du Sud,
on peut tuer d'autres Africains,
en Guinée équatoriale,
on peut en chasser d'autres,
on n'en veut pas.
Ne suivez pas la rue,
la rue ne construit pas la nation,
ce sont les élites qui le font.
Ce que nous voulons faire,
ce n'est pas du nationalisme,
ce n'est même pas antifrançais,
car si on faisait
une organisation anti,
avec des ressentiments...
On veut le dialogue avec la France
pour trouver des solutions,
car ce que nous voulons fabriquer,
tous, aussi presque 15 millions
d'afro-descendants
qui sont français et donc,
cette Afrique ne pourra
se construire
sans cette France-là.
Mais se focaliser sur des gens
qui hurlent dans la rue,
vous m'avez pas vue
hurler avec eux,
vous n'avez pas vu
ceux qui bâtissent l'Afrique
hurler avec eux,
ce ne sont que de hurleurs,
laissons-les faire leur job
et ce n'est pas pour autant
qu'on va remettre
en question un tout,
des choses belles se font,
des choses n'ont pas été très bien,
qu'on peut rectifier,
rectifions-les.
Pour l'économie,
même la francophonie,
complètement pervertie,
qui était une organisation
culturelle,
d'abord, hein, linguistique,
qui était là
pour que les peuples échangent,
aient une plate-forme culturelle.
On en a fait un instrument
politique, du coup,
ça a éloigné les peuples
de la francophonie,
ça concerne que les politiques
et on en a marre.
J'ai conçu un projet, monsieur,
par rapport à cette francophonie,
qui a été adopté et qui n'a pas
été mis sur pied depuis 2002.
Ca a été adopté par les 56 Etats
et aucun Etat ne le pratique,
on est parti chercher des femmes
qui ne parlent même pas le français
pour nous incarner.
Où est-on, monsieur ?
Il est temps qu'on règle les choses
et moi, je tiens
à ce que ça aille bien,
vous savez pourquoi ?
Parce que mes descendants
sont de ce pays
et si ça va mal avec l'Afrique,
je ne sais pas où ils vont aller.
Donc nous n'allons pas
nous focaliser
sur les hurleurs,
ça n'a pas de sens.
-On vous a entendue,
madame Beyala.
Euh, Nicolas Baverez,
vous avez entendu
Calixthe Beyala :
l'Afrique ne veut plus
d'aucun impérialisme
et l'Afrique se veut
souveraine.
Elle veut être libre
de créer sa monnaie,
de commercer avec qui elle veut,
d'élargir
ses partenariats à sa guise.
Est-ce qu'elle en a les moyens ?
-Ah, euh, tout à fait, oui,
puisqu'aujourd'hui,
si vous voulez, quand on regarde,
et c'est vrai que,
sans doute, ça a été,
comme il a été dit,
très mal compris par la France,
l'Afrique fait partie
du Sud global.
En réalité,
l'Afrique s'est largement
déjà émancipée.
Quand on regarde
le développement qui a eu lieu
depuis les années 2000,
alors qui a buté sur la pandémie
et qui bute aujourd'hui sur la crise
alimentaire,
mais ce continent a enfin décollé
et il a une croissance
de 5,5 % par an.
-Oui, mais 5 %,
quand on va de très bas,
c'est pas comme 2 %
quand on est très haut.
-Oui, mais la dynamique,
ce qui est important,
c'est quand la croissance économique
devient supérieure
à la croissance démographique.
Ce jour-là, incontestablement...
Alors, ce qu'on peut critiquer,
ça a été dit,
c'est que c'est valable
pour le continent,
c'est 56 pays, très différents,
donc évidemment, dans ces pays,
vous en avez à 10 % de croissance,
effectivement, le Rwanda,
le Rwanda ou autres,
et y en a sur lesquels c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus compliqué,
notamment dans la zone
subsaharienne.
Mais ce qu'il faut comprendre,
et là où ce développement importe,
c'est qu'il était
assez largement autocentré,
c'est un développement
assis sur celui des villes,
un début de constitution
des classes moyennes,
une diversification des économies.
En réalité,
l'Afrique a effectivement
une démographie
extrêmement dynamique,
elle a des ressources majeures,
et très importantes,
elle a des problèmes de sécurité,
des problèmes
de transition climatique,
mais en tout cas, aujourd'hui,
les Africains,
et les Africains se dotent
des moyens de leur développement,
j'en parlais tout à l'heure,
par exemple la grande zone
de libre-échange
panafricaine,
c'est un instrument
extrêmement puissant.
Donc le franc CFA,
il faut être clair,
le franc CFA appartient
aux Africains et s'ils veulent...
-Justement.
-...en sortir,
c'est plus du tout quelque chose
qui est piloté.
Regardez, par exemple,
le problème, aujourd'hui,
y a deux problèmes en Afrique,
la crise alimentaire et la dette,
mais la dette ne se règle plus
à Paris et à Bercy,
la dette africaine,
elle est essentiellement
entre les mains de la Chine.
-Mais alors justement,
Georges Serre,
répondez-moi clairement
sur un point précis :
est-ce qu'on peut
supprimer le franc CFA
et est-ce que ça aiderait l'Afrique
à avoir sa souveraineté
économique ?
-Dans les statuts
du Fonds monétaire,
ce qui est recherché
par le Fonds monétaire,
c'est une cohérence globalisée
des financements,
des budgets,
donc ce qui se retrouve
effectivement
dans les zones monétaires
comme la zone euro,
aujourd'hui, la zone euro,
dont d'ailleurs
fait partie la zone CFA,
on appelle ça la zone CFA,
mais ça fait partie,
c'est un élément de la zone euro.
Donc la tendance,
c'est de privilégier
des rassemblements dans lesquels
on peut effectivement
mutualiser
un certain nombre de financements,
de budgétisations.
Et la preuve est que,
si le Mali et la Centrafrique
aujourd'hui peuvent encore payer
les fonctionnaires,
c'est qu'ils font partie de la zone
franc et que les mécanismes...
-Donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
le garder pour le moment ?
-Bah, en Afrique de l'Ouest,
le débat qui s'est
posé aujourd'hui,
c'est au sein de la CEDEAO,
de la monnaie qui s'appelle l'eco.
Sa première phase,
c'est la consolidation
de l'Union économique
et monétaire ouest-africaine,
soit le CFA d'Afrique de l'Ouest.
En ce qui concerne
le CFA d'Afrique centrale,
bon, bah il est là,
pour l'instant, il fonctionne,
et puis faut pas oublier que,
dans cette zone euro
où y a la zone franc
d'Afrique de l'Ouest
et centrale, y a aussi
les Comores
et les Etats du Pacifique.
Donc c'est un peu plus large,
mais il faut retenir
que l'objectif du Fonds monétaire
est d'avoir de tels éléments,
et ça va dans le sens
de la Zone économique globale
de l'Afrique parce que
économie autocentrée,
mal ouverte encore
sur la mondialisation,
5 %, 6 % à peine du commerce
international.
Aujourd'hui, l'Afrique,
il faut qu'elle commerce entre elle.
Quand on se projette sur le futur,
y a une zone, moi,
j'aime bien le rappeler aux gens,
tout le bassin au sud
du fleuve Congo,
ce sont des terres qui sont à 300
ou 400 mètres d'altitude,
il y a de l'eau,
c'est le futur grenier
de céréales du monde.
-La nouvelle Ukraine.
-Tout à fait,
très belle formule, quelque part,
c'est là qui va
se passer des choses.
Ca voudra dire
que les gens doivent s'entendre,
les Angolais,
parce qu'il faut des lignes
de chemin de fer
sur l'Atlantique,
les Congolais, etc.
Donc quelque part,
ça fonctionnera ainsi,
il faut aller vers une entente.
-Alors, on passe
du CFA au stratégique, amiral.
D'un point de vue stratégique,
même si la division
du monde n'est plus
à l'aune de la Guerre froide,
on a eu la crise sanitaire,
on a la guerre en Ukraine,
il y a une espèce de clivage
qui s'observe
entre l'Occident
et les puissances
autoritaires,
pour ne pas dire antidémocratiques.
Est-ce que vous pensez que,
aujourd'hui,
l'Afrique risque
de basculer de ce côté-là ?
-Je ne crois pas.
Comme le disait madame Beyala
tout à l'heure,
les Africains veulent être
par eux-mêmes
et vivre par eux-mêmes.
Et si nous, d'un point de vue
stratégie militaire,
nous sommes restés trop
à l'intérieur de la sphère militaire
en oubliant l'extérieur,
d'autres font une tentative.
Wagner,
ce n'est pas seulement
une milice de mercenaires,
c'est d'abord un système économique.
Comment est financé Wagner
en République centrafricaine
et au Mali ?
Par des contrats sur les mines,
les mines d'or,
de tout ce que vous voulez,
les mines de sel y compris,
au Mali.
Wagner se paie directement,
si j'ose dire,
pardonnez-moi l'expression,
sur la bête.
Je pense que ça,
ça ne peut pas fonctionner,
ça ne peut pas durer, en Afrique.
La Chine, elle,
est arrivée uniquement
comme bailleur de fonds,
comme bailleur de fonds
et quand on va,
Georges Serre
connaît bien Kinshasa,
y a deux quartiers chinois
à Kinshasa totalement isolés
et qui sont à la limite,
si les Chinois faisaient
des bêtises,
je parle du gouvernement chinois,
pas de ceux qui sont sur place,
qui seraient finalement des otages
des populations locales.
-Oui,
mais qui s'assemble se ressemble,
dit le proverbe.
-Oui, bien sûr, mais...
-Est-ce qu'une présence chinoise
très forte,
une présence russe forte,
une présence turque
forte, etc.,
n'amènera pas
un basculement aussi
de régime ?
Vous pensez pas ça ?
-Je pense que,
de même que nous avons peut-être
commis l'erreur, nous,
Occidentaux, de vouloir faire
exporter directement
nos propres systèmes politiques
sur une Afrique qui avait
d'autres traditions, ancestrales,
donc ethniques,
et je pense que c'est...
Les Russes ou les Chinois,
voire les Turcs,
qui sont trois systèmes totalement
différents,
font sans doute
la même erreur.
L'avenir politique
de l'Afrique se fera
par les Africains,
pas en...
plaquant, finalement,
ou en imitant,
euh, avec des conditions en réalité
de pression et de température
qui sont totalement différentes.
-Antoine Glaser,
de ce que vous savez de ce qui
se passe en Afrique,
avez-vous le sentiment
que la Chine, la Russie,
dans leur coopération
avec l'Afrique,
apportent
de la prospérité à ce continent ?
Et de la stabilité politique ?
-Moi, je reviendrais...
-Parce que,
il faut savoir, si on critique
la Françafrique comme on le fait,
si on considère qu'il faut revoir
la politique de coopération,
est-ce que la mondialisation,
aujourd'hui,
profite à l'Afrique
à travers les échanges
avec la Chine, la Russie,
la Turquie, le Brésil ?
-Bien sûr.
La mondialisation,
l'Afrique est mondialisée,
je vais pas répéter les choses,
mais il faut qu'on sorte
de cette période historique
qui était cette période...
-Mais on est là,
aujourd'hui.
-Mais justement,
si on continue à voir
l'Afrique avec les stratégies
des anciennes puissances coloniales,
on comprend rien.
Même la Russie, ils font ça
à bas bruit et à bas prix,
ça a été dit, Wagner ne dépense pas,
comme le fait la France,
un ou deux milliards d'euros
du contribuable pour son armée.
Je veux dire,
ils font ça à bas bruit,
avec une stratégie,
ils surfent sur les sentiments
d'une autre période historique,
mais c'est la mondialisation
de l'Afrique
et vraiment l'Afrique des Africains.
Les gens doivent
comprendre...
Un pays comme le Gabon,
vous avez à peu près
un million d'habitants
et le Nigeria, 200 millions :
les problèmes n'ont rien
à voir les uns avec les autres.
On peut pas toujours dire
"les Afrique",
mais il faut quand même parler
des Afrique,
avec l'Afrique du Sud,
l'Afrique australe,
qui est un sous-continent,
il faut que la France,
comme les autres
puissances extérieures,
apprenne de l'Afrique,
comprenne l'Afrique.
Qu'est-ce que l'Afrique
et les Africains ?
Sur les matières premières
et autres, l'erreur de la France,
vous disiez tout à l'heure,
par rapport aux Anglais,
les Français ont eu,
alors pour le meilleur
et pour le pire,
c'était toujours une colonisation,
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'aimait
que les Africains
qui nous ressemblaient
selon une politique
assimilationniste.
Les Anglais,
c'est le pire et le meilleur,
le pire avec l'apartheid
en Afrique du Sud,
le meilleur,
c'est chacun dans son club.
Les filles de Chibok
qui se font enlever au Nigeria,
jamais un ministre anglais
ne s'en est occupé,
en dehors de Michelle Obama
avec son "bring back our girls".
Il faut arrêter de penser qu'on peut
faire le bonheur de l'Afrique,
il faut laisser l'Afrique
aux Africains.
Il faut arrêter avec ça.
-L'Afrique aux Africains.
Calixthe Beyala,
vous vivez à Paris, je crois,
de ce que vous savez
et de ce que vous entendez,
est-ce que
la présence chinoise,
la présence russe,
l'amiral Guillaud vient de dire
que les Russes,
via la sécurité de Wagner,
se paient en pillant
les mines,
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
que ces puissances
comme la Chine,
la Russie,
ne se comportent pas
comme des puissances
prédatrices,
comme on a accusé
la Françafrique de l'être ?
L'Afrique est-elle immunisée
contre ces prédations,
en quelque sorte ?
-Ce qu'il est important de savoir,
c'est que les Africains
ne connaissent pas les Russes.
Même si Wagner existe,
on ne les connaît pas.
Pas plus que les Chinois,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils viennent là
peut-être faire leurs routes,
ils vivent dans leur coin,
y a pas de contact
en tant que tel
entre les popu...
Je vis aussi
en Afrique,
c'est important,
je vis la plupart du temps
en Afrique,
depuis quelques années.
-Dans quel pays ?
-Au Cameroun,
essentiellement au Cameroun,
je connais bien la Centrafrique,
mes frères sont généraux
en Centrafrique
donc je connais très bien
la situation en Centrafrique
ou en Guinée équatoriale, bon,
on ne les connaît pas, déjà,
donc ce qui est important de dire
est que la relation à la France
paraît beaucoup plus violente,
pourquoi ?
Parce que c'est une relation
un peu plus fusionnelle,
c'est-à-dire
une relation qui date,
un vieux couple
qui est là, depuis des décennies,
des générations, qui a produit
des enfants,
des petits-enfants,
et évidemment,
c'est pas pareil qu'une relation
avec un inconnu.
Je veux dire que les Africains
connaissent les Français.
Les Français ne connaissent
pas les Africains,
c'est là où on a d'abord péché :
en France,
on n'a pas eu la curiosité
de connaître les Africains
et ce n'est même pas juste
de l'assimilationnisme,
les Africains les plus faibles,
la France a toujours travaillé
avec les populations,
enfin, choisi parmi nous
les éléments les plus faibles.
Or, les éléments
les plus faibles sont
les éléments dangereux,
pardon de le dire comme ça,
ce sont eux qu'on a mis en place
et qui ont créé
la situation actuelle et pillé
les pays, parce que quand
on parle de la Françafrique,
quand on parle du franc CFA,
c'est à cause de l'obscurité autour
de la question.
-Il y avait un système opaque.
-Voilà.
Et donc, les peuples
ne veulent plus de ça.
On a des dictateurs en place,
la France les a évidemment mis
en place en choisissant
les éléments les plus faibles,
qui n'ont jamais eu le courage
d'affronter leur peuple
et leurs difficultés.
Mais je ne mets pas
la seule responsabilité
sur la France, nous aussi.
Si vous allez au Cameroun,
ils sont là depuis 60 ans,
ils n'ont rien fait.
La misère est
essentiellement la cause
de ce ressentiment envers vous.
Les Africains sont pauvres,
riches et pauvres à la fois,
on a quelques familles
qui ont tout,
le reste qui mange du soleil,
qui boit du sable et c'est ça,
le vrai problème.
C'est pas la démocratie
le problème, en tant que tel,
c'est la misère car on a des gens
qui confisquent tout, voilà.
-Nicolas Baverez ?
-Oui, juste prolonger
ce qui a été dit,
et aussi dans la continuité
de ce que vous avez dit.
L'Afrique aux Africains,
évidemment,
dans ce sens où,
comme tous les pays,
les nations, les continents,
c'est des nations et des continents,
des peuples qui ont vocation
à prendre leur destin en main.
En revanche, je pense que la France,
on a beaucoup parlé de France,
mais c'est l'Europe
plus fondamentalement,
on ne peut se désintéresser
de l'Afrique,
parce que, vous l'avez dit,
y a des liens humains permanents,
y a des enjeux qui sont permanents,
on sait que la percée du djihad
en Afrique a des conséquences
immédiates sur l'Europe,
on sait que,
si le développement échoue,
évidemment,
y aura des problèmes
de migration majeurs,
on sait également
que si les choses, à l'inverse,
fonctionnent bien,
c'est le grand continent
émergent du 21e siècle
et donc,
c'est pour ça qu'il faut imaginer
des logiques de codéveloppement et,
dans ces logiques,
c'est pour ça que, moi,
je sais que, économiquement,
le gros problème du franc CFA,
en réalité,
c'est que, comme il y a
le lien avec l'euro,
c'est une monnaie surévaluée,
donc qui pose des problèmes
de compétitivité.
Mais à l'inverse,
il a cet avantage qui permet
à des pays de travailler ensemble
et de commercer.
Regardez, le contre-exemple,
c'est le Maghreb :
c'est une aberration
qu'il y ait pas un grand marché
du Maghreb.
On a des pays qui s'opposent
et c'est un obstacle
majeur au développement.
Donc vous voyez, c'est pour ça
que les choses sont compliquées,
l'Afrique aux Africains, évidemment,
au sens où c'est évidemment pas
à la France d'aller choisir
les dirigeants ou d'intervenir.
-On vous a entendu.
-En revanche,
on ne peut pas perdre l'Afrique
et on ne peut pas laisser
des puissances
comme la Chine ou la Russie,
donc la Chine,
c'est la dépendance à la dette,
la Russie, c'est très violent
et c'est Wagner,
la Turquie, c'est la religion,
mais on ne peut pas laisser
ces pays...
-Mais ils ne nous demandent
pas l'autorisation.
-Oui, y a une compétition,
il faut qu'on joue le jeu
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui.
-Via un dialogue.
-Antoine Glaser,
y a un point que j'aimerais
éclaircir avec vous,
les forces
armées africaines sont censées
s'occuper de la sécurité
du continent
africain.
On dit qu'elles sont,
dans l'ensemble, corrompues.
Est-ce que c'est exact
et, dans ce cas-là,
à qui revient d'assurer la sécurité
du continent africain ?
-Non, mais je veux dire,
elles sont corrompues,
c'est pas les armées
qui sont corrompues,
ce sont des systèmes.
Y a eu toute une période
où finalement la France
s'était un peu substituée
aux armées africaines nationales,
dans cette période, voilà,
qu'on appelle post-coloniale.
C'est vrai que des présidents
comme Houphouët-Boigny préférait
avoir une garde présidentielle
et il préférait
que ce soit les Français
qui assurent sa sécurité
avec le 43e BIMa.
Donc c'est aussi, d'abord,
c'est vrai qu'on est là pour parler
de la France en Afrique,
y a une responsabilité énorme
évidemment des dirigeants africains,
les dirigeants africains ont peur,
et à juste titre pour certains,
de coups d'Etat de leurs militaires.
Longtemps, ils ont préféré demander
à la France d'assurer leur sécurité
plutôt que de former
leurs propres officiers.
Mais encore une fois,
il faut quand même
comprendre ce qui se passe
en Afrique avec toute cette zone
depuis la Mauritanie jusqu'au Soudan
où y a plus d'Occidentaux,
les djihadistes ont réussi,
mais c'est pas simplement
les djihadistes,
c'est parfois aussi des réseaux
islamistes plus ou moins radicaux,
peut-être de Saoudiens,
peut-être de Qatariens et autres
qui font du prosélytisme
aussi dans toute cette région.
On est dans une nouvelle
période historique.
Alors évidemment que les Chinois,
eux font l'économie,
la Russie va faire
surtout la sécurité
et aussi un certain type de matières
premières,
pour aussi pouvoir
vendre des petites
centrales nucléaires.
Mais il faut vraiment voir ça
avec un grand angle
et comprendre qu'on n'est plus...
On parle du CFA,
mais ceux qui défendent le CFA,
car le CFA est politique,
il est économique mais il reste,
aux yeux d'un certain
nombre d'Africains,
il est très politique,
ce sont les dirigeants africains
et vous allez pas pouvoir
renverser les Etats.
Il faut laisser du temps au temps,
y a un certain nombre de jeunes
Africains, ça va se développer,
y aura des bouleversements
comme on a vu
dernièrement en Chine,
les choses évoluent aussi.
Les choses évoluent, mais nous,
on s'est mis quelque part hors jeu
parce qu'on voyait pas les enjeux,
localement.
On s'est un peu endormis,
on s'est endormis dans une Afrique
qui était plus la nôtre
et où on s'est cru encore chez nous.
Donc il faut laisser du temps
au temps et laisser
l'Afrique se développer.
Je suis complètement d'accord
avec Calixthe Beyala,
faut arrêter de dire aux Africains :
attention,
les Chinois vont vous exploiter,
attention, les Russes !
Laissons-les, laissons-les.
J'aimerais un jour faire un livre
en disant "démerdez-vous",
je veux dire, laissons les Africains
se démerder avec l'affaire !
-Bien, je ne sais pas
si on va reprendre
la formule d'Antoine Glaser,
mais en tout cas,
on parle beaucoup
de démographie en disant que,
en 2050,
y aura deux milliards,
plus de deux milliards
d'Africains,
est-ce que, à votre avis,
Calixthe Beyala,
l'Afrique est prête à faire face
à cette montée démographique
et, surtout,
qui pour assurer son développement,
quand on voit certains chercheurs
comme Stephen Smith,
qui considère
que ceux qui quittent l'Afrique
sont souvent
des gens de qualité
et bien formés ?
-Bien, je pense...
-Quand on parle de l'avenir, hein.
-Oui, absolument,
je suis consciente qu'il y aura
deux milliards d'Africains en 2050
et je crois que
c'est une très bonne chose
car à tout boom économique
précède un boom démographique.
On peut pas faire des Etats,
par exemple en Guinée
équatoriale, avec 700 000 personnes.
Qui consomme ? Personne.
On peut pas faire des Etats
avec un million de personnes.
L'Afrique est sous-peuplée,
mais dynamique, d'ailleurs,
parce qu'on a une jeunesse énorme.
Quand on a 40 ans,
en Afrique, on est
presque trop vieux,
les autres ont 20 ans.
C'est formidable.
Contrairement à ce qu'on croit,
les gens sont hyper-formés.
Vous prenez
un pays comme le Cameroun,
si vous leur donnez des instruments,
même pour faire
des microprocesseurs,
ils vous le feront,
tellement on a formé nos enfants,
notamment au niveau du Cameroun,
on a créé des universités,
nous-mêmes,
c'est pas l'Etat, partout,
on a formé nos jeunes.
Ils sont prêts.
Ce qui nous manque, aujourd'hui,
c'est peut-être, disons,
pour impulser toutes ces choses,
c'est-à-dire pas corrompus,
pas qui dorment chez eux,
pas 90 ans au pouvoir
et qui puissent permettre
à l'Afrique de démarrer.
Et ça va se faire car, vraiment,
la nouvelle génération
a des gens de qualité.
Ensuite, l'immigration
a toujours eu lieu,
et c'est une bonne chose
pour tout le monde,
et j'espère qu'il y aura
de l'immigration
de la France et de l'Europe
vers l'Afrique.
C'est un jeu permanent,
et qui a permis
à l'humanité d'évoluer,
il faut qu'on évolue tous
et qu'on dépasse certaines choses.
On ne dira pas à l'Afrique
"démerdez-vous" car la France
aura aussi besoin
de l'Afrique,
nous aurons besoin
les uns des autres.
C'est pour ça
que le discours...
-Démerdons-nous.
-Oui, démerdons-nous,
et je pense que le plus urgent,
aujourd'hui,
pour la France, c'est de...
d'impulser un dialogue
avec les Africains.
C'est ce qui manque, de les écouter
et que, ensemble, on puisse tirer
des conclusions et avoir
un canevas à suivre.
-Georges Serre,
est-ce que vous êtes
aussi optimiste par rapport
au défi démographique ?
-La résilience, en Afrique,
c'est quelque chose de formidable
et c'est tout à fait humain,
c'est comme ça
que l'humanité s'est créée
depuis 100 000 ans, depuis...
Sapiens vient bien d'Afrique,
tout le monde le dit aujourd'hui.
Alors, un pays comme le Niger,
chaque fois
que les gens regardaient,
par exemple en 1950,
les gens disaient, les économistes :
500 000 personnes au Niger,
c'est pas praticable,
ça ne pourra jamais suffire.
Et ainsi de suite.
La Banque mondiale dit, en 1975 :
plus de six millions au Niger,
c'est pas possible, on a déjà brûlé
tout autour de Niamey.
Aujourd'hui,
y a 20 millions d'habitants
et y a pas eu de grande famine
depuis 15 ans,
elles étaient liées
à des sécheresses.
Donc il y a une résilience,
les gens apprennent à cultiver.
On a parlé tout à l'heure
de grenier futur
de l'Afrique,
donc ça ne me fait pas peur,
au contraire, c'est un atout d'avoir
cette jeunesse.
Les gens se débrouillent
aujourd'hui, en plus.
Les grandes villes comme Lagos,
Abidjan, les grandes...
Les gens se débrouillent
parce qu'ils ont intérêt
à survivre
en utilisant des moyens à la fois
modernes et traditionnels.
Donc ils continueront
à cultiver des plantes anciennes
et en même temps
se tourner vers l'informatique.
J'ai vu, effectivement,
dans certains pays,
des jeunes à peine formés
sur l'informatique par des plus âgés
qui construisent
des ordinateurs.
C'est ça, la vraie Afrique.
-Vous en pensez quoi,
amiral ?
La transition
démographique...
-Je suis surpris,
et agréablement surpris
par plusieurs phénomènes.
Y a 20 ans, on expliquait que,
à cause de l'épidémie de SIDA,
la population d'Afrique
allait tomber, en 2020,
serait en dessous
de 500 millions d'habitants.
Donc là,
les démographes
et les épidémiologistes
se sont largement trompés.
Du coup, les deux milliards,
peut-être un milliard et demi,
mais c'est formidable.
Pour aller encore assez
régulièrement en Afrique,
je suis toujours... enthousiasmé,
y a pas d'autre mot,
par la volonté de la jeunesse.
Je donne cours
dans une université
qui est à 150 kilomètres de Dakar,
qui est celle de Bambey,
où l'on forme
des jeunes pour les besoins locaux,
pas pour aller
les exporter aux Etats-Unis,
ou en Europe,
mais bien pour les besoins
du Sénégal,
voire d'autres pays.
Donc, intellectuellement,
tout y est,
y compris la volonté.
C'est vrai par ailleurs
que ça bouillonne,
car 70 % de la population
a moins de 30 ans,
donc c'est assez naturel.
C'est vrai que c'est assez pratique
de trouver un bouc émissaire,
hein, c'est...
Et la Françafrique en est un,
la troisième
période de la Françafrique,
comme disait Nicolas Baverez,
on est loin de la première.
D'un autre côté,
c'est à nous d'aider
les Africains à acquérir
les bons instruments,
c'est pas vendre,
il s'agit pas de ça,
il s'agit de les aider,
s'ils le souhaitent,
et avec eux,
et non ps de leur dire :
voilà votre solution.
Ca, ça ne marchera pas.
Du coup, oui, on y arrive,
c'est vrai y compris
au point de vue sécuritaire.
La sécurité,
ce qu'on oublie de dire un peu,
c'est qu'un certain nombre
de chefs d'Etat
africains sont
d'anciens militaires,
c'est la raison pour laquelle,
au pouvoir,
ils ne veulent surtout pas
que leur armée soit compétente
car ils ont peur d'être renversés
par un autre militaire.
D'où, et on revient a ce qui a été
dit déjà deux fois ce soir,
eh bien on déléguait la sécurité,
plus ou moins, à l'ex-puissance
coloniale.
Je pense que
ce temps est passé, maintenant,
et que les nouvelles générations
ne l'accepteront plus.
Et c'est tant mieux.
-Ecoutez,
il nous reste très peu de temps.
Je voudrais...
L'Afrique,
c'est un très grand continent,
avec au nord un pays
comme l'Algérie,
au sud l'Afrique du Sud,
tout ça est très complexe,
c'est des Afrique.
On a très peu de temps,
en une minute,
chacun d'entre vous,
qu'est-ce qui est souhaitable,
au niveau de l'Afrique ?
Est-ce que c'est
une union africaine,
comme il y en a,
comme on a fait l'Union Européenne ?
Mais qui a des défaillances,
on le constate aujourd'hui,
notamment sur l'énergie.
Quels voeux vous formulez
à ce sujet ?
-C'est le voeu
des peuples d'Afrique
que je veux formuler,
on veut du panafricanisme,
c'est-à-dire la construction
des Etats fédérés,
gouvernés...
Et c'est accepté
par le peuple africain
et pas par les dirigeants,
tout le peuple,
c'est ce qu'il veut,
le panafricanisme,
et c'est très facile parce que,
hormis l'arabe dans le nord,
le reste de l'Afrique, en fait,
il y a que trois grandes
langues,
ce sont les langues bantoues,
les langues à claque
de l'Afrique australe,
les langues
de l'Afrique de l'Ouest
avec le foulbé.
Donc c'est très facile.
On est déjà très en avance,
on a travaillé sur ces langues,
on a choisi de parler,
par exemple,
l'arabe, le français, l'anglais,
le swahili et le foulbé,
les cinq langues choisies
pour cette Afrique de demain.
Donc nous sommes déjà très avancés,
on a déjà travaillé
sur les socles communs,
ce que nous devons avoir en commun
au niveau de la pensée...
Bon, je peux pas tout développer.
-Merci.
Un mot là-dessus ?
Mais un mot, on n'a plus de temps.
-Premièrement,
l'Afrique va être le seul
continent en expansion
et qui va être un continent jeune
dans un monde qui va
beaucoup vieillir.
Deuxièmement, oui,
c'est la logique de l'intégration
qui est la bonne
et tout ce qui peut la promouvoir,
y compris autour des pays qui sont
les pays un peu structurants,
c'est-à-dire Nigeria,
Afrique du Sud,
Egypte, Algérie, Maroc.
Et la dernière chose,
et je le répète,
ce que vous avez appelé dialogue,
on peut l'appeler codéveloppement
et c'est un enjeu vital
pour la France et l'Europe
et on peut pas s'en désintéresser.
Autant l'Afrique
se développera par elle-même
mais pas seule non plus.
-Antoine Glaser,
très bref.
-En tant que Français,
je pense que c'est vraiment
l'heure d'apprendre de l'Afrique,
de s'intéresser vraiment
à l'Afrique des Africains,
donc d'arrêter les leçons
et de s'intéresser.
On a trop longtemps exporté
dans ces pays... pas simplement
une constitution et la langue,
il faut apprendre de l'Afrique
et s'intéresser
à ce qu'elle est réellement.
Y a un gros travail à faire,
quelques chercheurs le font,
mais très peu.
-Amiral Guillaud,
là-dessus ?
-Si on considère, je crois que
c'est le cas autour de cette table,
que le continent majeur
du 22e siècle sera l'Afrique,
c'est donc au 21e siècle
qu'il va prendre...
et que nous,
nous sommes sur une pente
descendante,
c'est une simple observation,
eh bien allions-nous,
ne laissons pas passer le train
et les Africains le méritent.
-Votre voeu africain,
Georges Serre ?
-Pour compléter ce qui a été dit,
laisser aussi la place
au financement du secteur privé,
le moteur de l'Afrique aujourd'hui,
le vrai moteur de l'Afrique,
qu'elle se développe de manière
harmonieuse et solide.
-Ecoutez, merci, madame,
merci, messieurs.
On ne se lassera jamais de faire
des émissions sur l'Afrique.
Avant de nous quitter,
je voudrais vous signaler
une bibliographie.
Alors, Kako Nubupko,
qui est un ancien ministre,
vient de publier ce livre.
Vous l'avez lu, madame Beyala ?
-Non, pas encore,
mais je le lirai avec plaisir.
-Alors je vous l'offre
avec plaisir, voilà.
Calixthe Beyala, vous,
vous avez publié
un ouvrage...
Alors, j'ai choisi ça.
En un mot, c'est quoi,
le Christ selon l'Afrique ?
-Parce qu'il y a des églises,
des pasteurs à tous
les coins de rue et des prophètes.
Et c'est un pourrissement,
aussi, spirituel pour l'Afrique.
C'est de ça que je parle.
-Je voudrais également signaler
un livre qui vient de sortir
et qui est assez exhaustif
sur l'Algérie,
l'Algérie du 19e siècle,
du 20e siècle et du 21e siècle.
Nous avons également,
je voudrais signaler votre livre,
Antoine Glaser,
fait avec Pascal Airault.
Est-ce que vous pensez que Macron
apprend de mieux en mieux
à connaître et gérer l'Afrique ?
-Oui, parce qu'on l'entend
de moins en moins.
Rires
Donc il a compris que,
sur l'Afrique,
il devait faire voeu de silence.
Et on ne l'entend plus.
-Bien, écoutez,
voilà une observation.
Nicolas Baverez,
vous pensez que la démocratie
est en danger.
On a toujours besoin d'agiter
ce drapeau démocratique ?
-Ah, plus que jamais.
La liberté n'est jamais donnée,
c'est un combat et, en ce moment,
un combat de plus en plus compliqué,
c'est vrai en Afrique,
c'est vrai sur tous les continents.
-Merci, madame Calixthe Beyala,
merci, messieurs,
d'avoir participé
à cette émission.
Je voudrais
remercier notre excellente
équipe à LCP
et, avant de nous quitter,
vous laisser avec cette réflexion
de Pierre de Villiers,
qui a également été
chef d'état-major des Armées :
"Je crains que
le désengagement français
"n'accélère une déstructuration
de certains pays
"africains au profit de puissances
"comme la Chine et la Russie."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA